[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue merci
d'être présent à notre rendez vous
quotidien pour cette nouvelle semaine
nous accueillons aujourd'hui pour
débattre de l'actualité nicolas baverez
bonsoir en soit vous êtes avocat
économistes éditorialiste au figaro où
vous retrouve chaque lundi
votre chronique de ce jour est consacré
à la politique économique à mettre en
place après le vide vous êtes aussi
essayiste et votre dernier livre
l'alertent démocratique a été publié aux
édition de l'observatoire bonsoir
alexandre vous est entre autres
responsable des pages débats du figaro
magazine
mais vous faites du coup de chaud de
figure vous êtes associé en charge du
figaro vox et vous avez néanmoins le
temps d'écrire des livres le dernier
recours éditions nouveau monde populiste
a été publié aux éditions du cerf encan
si vous le voulez bien cette émission
avec ce dérapage xxl de jean-luc
mélenchon
at il été mal compris at il dit quelque
chose de vraiment choquant en tout cas
il a laissé entendre hier que les
événements graves
du type des attentats de toulouse qui
surviennent pendant une élection
présidentielle peuvent être
instrumentalisés alors est ce que pour
autant il met des responsables ou non
derrière ça pour vous faire votre propre
opinion je vous propose de réécouter
cette séquence c'était donc hier sur
france inter vous verrez que dans la
dernière semaine de la campagne
présidentielle nous aurons graves
incidents alors ça a été ou est un
meurtre ça a été mais ras en 2012
ça a été là quand à la dernière semaine
sur les champs elysées vous rappeler de
tout ça c'était la dernière semaine
avant on a bu papy voise dont plus
personne n'a jamais entendu parler à
voir après donc tout ça c'est écrit
d'avancé
nous allons présenter le chapeau nous
aurons les événements gravissimes qui va
une fois de plus permettent de montrer
du doigt les musulmans et d'inventer une
guerre civile
voilà c'était bâton tout ça la phrase
qui a choqué c'est tout ça c'est écrit
d'avancé
choquée en particulier les victimes des
attentats de toulouse perpétrés par
mohamed merah en 2012 alors jean-luc
mélenchon at il été mal compris et il
allait trop loin at il perdu la raison
et bien je vous propose avoir trois
points de vue successifs d'abord la
défense
clémentine autain donc qui fait partie
du même mouvement politique que jean luc
mélenchon qui considère qu'il a été mal
compris ensuite on écoute michel barnier
qui lui considère que ce genre de propos
est indigne et après cédric au qui lui
évoque le complotisme cedrico vous le
savez c'est le secrétaire d'état chargé
de la transition numérique on les écoute
je suis en train de vous dire que ce
qu'il a dit c'est que les assassins
choisissent leur moment qu'ils
choisissent leur moment vous ne pouvez
pas le nier c'est un fait l'allemagne
veulent que ça retentissent et le
cherche à diviser le pays et souvent ils
y arrivent
jean luc mélenchon n'est pas
complotistes ce sont les assassins qu'il
vise dans ce moment là jean luc
mélenchon a toujours affirmé son soutien
aux victimes et je trouve indigne eux
quand on esprit mentalise ces attentats
ces drames
cette douleur qui est toujours là à des
fins d'argumentation politique ou de
conjoncture politique
sa rhétorique et touche quasiment aux
complotistes main c'est à dire on ne
comprend pas si c'est les terroristes
qui profite de la dernière semaine ou si
c'est prévu
si c'est le cas en tel est en tout cas
trop c'est assez abjecte évidemment de
mettre les événements toulouse meira
l'assassinât d'un certain nombre
d'enfants en tout cas de l'utiliser
politiquement de cette manière je trouve
ça assez faible et comme souvent quand
les sujet vous passionne vous êtes
nombreux à réagir sur twitter sur
youtube sur lefigaro.fr vous nous suivez
en direct
voici quelques points de vue d'autant
plus intéressant que ils sont divers
alex sur youtube nous dit on t'a
mélenchon qui a eu des propos
inadmissibles pour les victimes alors
qu'henri nous explique qu'à chaque
élection présidentielle il ya toujours
soit un attentat soient des faits divers
et que donc on est en droit de se poser
la question quant à francine l'estiment
qu'à chaque fois que quelqu'un à aimer
une opinion contraire à la doxa il est
catalogué complotistes quel est votre
intime conviction alexandre d'avec que
vous pensez que que mélenchon a été mal
compris ou qu'il a vraiment dépassé les
bornes
je pense qu'il a dépassé les bornes
après sur le mot complotisme je n'aime
pas ce mot là je trouve que c'est un peu
à bout comme populiste qu'on utilise
pour disqualifier l'adversaire ça
empêche de réfléchir je crois qu'il est
pas complotistes jean luc mélenchon et
les clientéliste c'est pas la même chose
parce que il
et dans une stratégie qui le conduit
inexorablement à sa perte
il avait fait une campagne intéressante
1 il ya cinq ans une campagne tricolore
populiste mais dans le bon sens du terme
et puis il ya eu les élections
législatives il a gagné en banlieue il
ya beaucoup de députés qui ont été élus
en banlieue et je crois qu'il a voulu il
a été prisonnier de cette clientèle
électorale à laquelle il a voulu donner
des gages on l'a vu à la manif contre
l'islamophobie qui était en réalité une
manif islamistes on l'a vu voilà se
mettre en joue avec les indigènes de la
république donc on voit qui va de plus
en plus loin pour plaire à une clientèle
communautariser qui serait peut-être
susceptible de voter pour lui dans les
banlieues je pense que là il s'aliène
surtout tout le reste de l'électorat
c'est pour ça que je pense que ça va
conduire à sa perte politique et là on
le on le voit bien on voit qu'il a
suscité une polémique et qui là qu'il a
choqué beaucoup de monde ce qui est
choquant dans ces propos c'est aussi le
mot ainsi dont je trouve assis dans
grave pour qualifier le meurtre
d'enfants juifs par mohamed merah pour
qualifier le meurtre d'un policier pour
qualifié l'agression sauvage de la route
restait donc je trouve que les mots sont
vraiment pas bien choisi qui en plus
c'est assez dangereux parce que voilà
après on se souvient qu'après charlie
hebdo qu'après le bataclan justement
dans les banlieues on expliquer que tout
ça c'était le mossad finalement et que
les vraies victimes n'étaient pas les
victimes mettait les musulmans donc je
sais pas s'il est conscient de reprendre
cette rhétorique mais il le fait encore
une fois je pense que c'est du cynisme
et cd chine qui ne pèsera pas et qui va
conduire à le marginaliser politiquement
nicolas baverez l'avocat que vous êtes
at il envie de prendre la défense de
juin avec mélenchon c'est vrai que c'est
très difficile en tout cas on peut
prendre sa défense au sens où je ne
crois pas du tout que
jean luc mélenchon soit complotistes je
crois qu'on vient de dire que c'est une
transgression qui est une transgression
extrême et en même temps calculé son
propos est absurde parce que d'abord on
ne voit pas qui serait derrière qu'ils
manipuleraient et qui bénéficierait
électoralement de ce type d'événement on
a eu des exemples d'événements de
d'attentats qui ont modifié les
élections le le grand exemple celle en
espagne la gare d'atocha où le parti
conservateur d'aznar avec son successeur
était parti pour gagner et c'est comme
ça que josé luis zapatero s'est retrouvé
gagnant parce que aznar a expliqué que
les responsables étaient le thé alors
que c'était un attentat islamiste mais
les moments où les attentats font les
élections en fait c'est extrêmement set
extrêmement rare donc cette absurde
parce qu'on voit pas qui ça profiterait
c'est vrai que c'est extrêmement
choquant insultant pour les familles des
victimes qui à juste titre sont
horrifiés mais là où finalement c'est
une transgression calculer c'est la
housse pour le coup c'est du vrai
populisme c'est que ça ressemble
donald trump aurait pu le faire donc ça
participe de cette dégradation de la vie
politique où finalement les dirigeants
volontairement tiennent des propos
extrêmes qui se s'adresse au socle dur
de leurs militants des propos dont ils
savent très bien qu'ils n'ont plus aucun
rapport avec la réalité mais qui sont
censés à la fois consolider leur base et
et j'allais dire concentré toute
l'attention à la communication est ici
et finalement tristement ce qui se passe
depuis sept
depuis cette déclaration donc alors
beaucoup moins dramatique mais tout
aussi
délirante on avait les déclarations de
monsieur pelletier sur le fait qu'on
allait rétablir des cours sûreté de
l'état qu'on allait juger des gens alors
même par anticipation
ça n'avait ni queue ni tête qu'on allait
supprimer la pelle
c'était aussi bête sur le sur l'état de
droit donc ce qui est très préoccupant
c'est que quelle est la réalité quand
même notre pays sort de cette épidémie
extrêmement malade
diminués extrêmement éclaté avec une
dette publique monstrueuse un appareil
de production
exemple est donc cette élection de 2022
c'est quand même la dernière occasion
d'essayer de traiter nos problèmes et si
on part comme ça alors il ya une chose
qui est certaine c'est que là ça veut
dire qu'on va parler de tout sauf des
problèmes de la france et des moyens de
la redresser
et c'est là où au delà de ski études
donc une transgression sinistre et
j'allais dire indigne
de ce qu'est jean luc mélenchon vraiment
et au fond c'est ça qui est préoccupant
c'est que si cette campagne doit se
réduire à ce concours de de débordements
et de transgression pour essayer de
capter un peu de temps médiatique là
notre pays est vraiment mal parti
parce que vous partagez avec son avec
eux le point de vue nicolas baverez qui
dit en fait personne ne tire vraiment
profite ce genre d'événement jean luc
mélenchon si tu es dans son interview
d'hier
papy voise papy voise enfin c'est comme
ça qu'on avait surnommé monsieur voix
c'était un était un retraité qui avait
été agressé très violemment
c'était le 21 avril 2002 donc quasiment
quelques heures avant avant l'élection
et
parti très jeune à l'époque mais bon
jean marie le pen s'est retrouvé au
second tour est ce que vous croyez pas
quand même qui avait il y avait un lien
entre entre les deux que les français
n'ont pas été choqué par par les images
de cet homme d'entente on voit le visage
tuméfié à l'écran dont le contexte de
l'époque ça a pu jouer parce que c'était
une qualification surprise de jean marie
le pen au second tour qui s'est
probablement joué à moins d'un point on
croit qu il était à 16 et quelques pour
cent et que lionel jospin était juste
derrière donc c'est possible que cet
événement lui ait permis de prendre le
point je dirais de la qualification mais
si vous voulez le débat de la sécurité à
l'époque était très installé ça avait
été le débat de la campagne et je crois
que c'était un problème de fond qu'il
fallait régler qui hélas n'a pas été
toujours pas réglé depuis et que ce qui
travaille la société sait les problèmes
structurels qu'on connaît depuis une
quarantaine d'années ces événements
quand il ya des événements trajet qui ça
ne fait que les les kung fu les
confirmés mais si vous voulez voilà la
société et travailler en profondeur par
cela et je crois que c'est toujours
risqué de les instrumentaliser je pense
que papy voise y avait pas salle il y
avait eu besoin de l'instrumentaliser
c'est l'événement lui même qui avait
fait qui a peut-être déclencher des
choses il y avait pas eu le temps
d'ailleurs vous le rappeliez c'était
quelques heures avant le vote pour ce
qu'elle mohamed merah c'est presque
amusant si j'ose dire si on peut être
abusée par ce genre de choses mais à
l'époque il avait été instrumentalisé
souvenez-vous plus tôt par jean luc
mélenchon sans doute par françois bayrou
qui expliquait quand on ne se
connaissait pas l'identité de mohamed
merah que à force d'agiter les peurs oui
nicolas sarkozy avait ressuscité le
terrorisme d'extrême d'extrême droite
donc et je pense que ça s'est retourné
contre eux
et oui c'est amusant d'entendre jean luc
mélenchon en dire ça parce que je suis
pratiquement certain que si on
retrouvait ses propos à l'époque il nous
disait attention le retour de la menace
fasciste et il a instrumentalisé lui
même ce genre de choses je pense qu'il
faut le faire avec food aux que les
politiques vous toujours tendance à le
faire mais que c'est bien normal qu'ils
allaient agissent tôt fait de
deux sociétés maintenant fou qui voient
leur travail et de trouver des solutions
et de pas être simplement des
commentateurs juste un mot un dernier
mot là dessus sur cet extrait moi ce qui
me choque bon hormis le voilà le fait
que jean luc mélenchon ne tombe de plus
en plus bas c'est le manque de réaction
du service public
je pense que des propos comme ça d'un
éditorialiste de droite auraient fait
réagir très vigoureusement sur le
plateau là on voit qu'il n'ya pas de
réaction qui a une certaine complaisance
c'est pas la première fois il ya
quelques semaines booba par exemple
expliqué que marine le pen était nazi
sans faire réagir personne je trouve
qu'il ya un problème aussi du service
public qui se montre extrêmement
partiale à avec certains et extrêmement
complaisant avec d'autres les
internautes ont marqué ça aussi je vais
vous repassez la parole je suis dit que
là-bas vrai mais on na na rang qui nous
dit que penser de la non réaction des
journalistes aux propos de jean luc
mélenchon c'est aussi choquant et puis
nicole c'est inadmissible elle fait
allusion aux propos du leader de la
france insoumise et en plus pas un seul
journaliste du service public pour le
reprendre je vous donne juste le point
de vue les internautes appelés à donner
leur avis sur twitter selon vous jean
luc mélenchon tient ty les propos
complotistes et vous répondez oui à 81%
c'est de la provocation estime chardon
bleu tandis que babineau considère que
mélenchon n'a toujours pas digéré
l'élection d' emmanuel macron et qu'il
entraîne son parti dans sa descente aux
enfers
je voulais juste dire un mot là aussi
pour être reprendre un peu de recul
c'est que notamment sur les attentats de
mohamed merah avec le recul on
s'aperçoit que en réalité ce qui est
étonnant c'est la faiblesse des
réactions par rapport à la gravité de ce
qui s'était passé et que finalement la
mobilisation qui a eu pour charlie hebdo
est ce que ça n'était pas au moins aussi
grave d'avoir quelqu'un qui comme il a
été rappelé et donc à tuer à cela mais
est rentrée dans une école juive et
étaient capables de
tirer et deux tuées à bout touchant une
petite fille de quatre ou cinq ans et
quand on regarde les réactions de la
société française et finalement elles
ont été pour le coup très très faible et
d'une certaine manière
moi j'aurais plutôt l'étonnement inverse
comment se fait-il qu'on n'ait pas perçu
davantage le le danger et comment se
fait-il qu'ils aient pas une réaction
plus importante par rapport à ce qui ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui avoir été un
signal annonciateur de cette grande
vague d attentats qu'ils vous répondrais
que je pense que c'est le résultat de
trente ondes antifascisme d'opérettes et
de chantage waras et je pense qu'il faut
le dire maintenant rétrospectivement on
le sait ce qui a gêné dans la fermera
ses classes à ça n'allait pas la bonne
couleur de peau est pas la bonne
religion on a commencé par réagir
voulait rappeler très vigoureusement en
pensons que c'était un néonazi or ce
n'était pas le cas où ça l'était mais
d'une autre manière et se revendiquait
de l'idéologie islamiste et ça on n'a
pas voulu le voir pendant très longtemps
ça nous a d'ailleurs fait perdre
beaucoup de temps parce que le
diagnostic qui a été fait à l'époque qui
avec gilles kepel était l'un des rares
aux experts à crier a expliqué que
c'était pas le cas mais à l'époque le
diagnostic qui avait été fait c'était
que c'était un loup solitaire
on a vu après qu'il y avait beaucoup de
loups solitaires et c'est vrai qu'on a
perdu je crois peut-être des années
entre 2012 et 2015
par la faute je crois d'un antiracisme
pseudo antiracistes qui a fait beaucoup
de mal à la société
avec le recul si vous voulez le jeu
rejoint ce qui est des mets donc le le
recul c'est que là l'erreur qui a été
commise à l'époque est exactement l
inverse de ce que dit jean luc mélenchon
sait que c'était un événement
extrêmement grave qui a finalement été
sous-estimée qui a été mal compris mal
analysé et qui a permis
heureusement ensuite un signal d alerte
qui n'a pas été perçue et qui nous a
coûté très cher par la suite passant si
vous le voulez bien un sujet économique
et fiscale ce week-end était réuni le g7
des ministres des finances est à dire
les responsables de ces portefeuilles
ministériels des sept plus grands pays
développés et ils ont prédit une
décision qu'on nous annonce comme étant
historique celle d'instaurer un impôt
minimum de 15% sur les multinationales
quel que soit le pays dans lesquels ces
entreprises opèrent alors évidemment il
faut maintenant convaincre au delà du g7
tous les autres pays importants de la
planète mais dès lors qu'il ya un
engagement d'un certain nombre de pays
en particulier les états unis
ça peut sembler en bonne voie écouter la
satisfaction de bruno le maire il était
l'invité hier du grand rendez vous et il
considère que nous pouvons être fiers
et qu'est-ce qui a fait que nous avons
réussi à trouver cet accord une
détermination de long terme de la france
je pense que tous les français peuvent
être fiers de ce résultat c'est leurs
résultats c'est le résultat des français
la france pèse encore sur la scène
internationale et ce que dit la france
est écoutée et respectée
c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps que
mono le maire plaidé pour cette type de
fiscalité minimum même si lui aurait
aimé à un niveau supérieur
nicolas barret vous connaissez bien le
monde de l'entreprise vous savez à quel
point les multinationales peuvent faire
preuve d'imagination de 2 d'apple à d
expertise très pointue pour payer le
moins d'impôt possible
vous y croyez à cet impôt mondial où est
ce que le jeu presque éternel entre les
avocats fiscalistes et les
administrations va continuer non c'est
clairement un vrai tournant c'est un
vrai tournant parce que
de fait d'abord on va modifier la base
de calcul de l'impôt donc il ya une
partie qui va être prise en compte dans
les pays où mouvant et pas seulement
dans les pays où on localise les profits
ensuite le mécanisme de rattrapage fait
que deux fait ça va tuer les paradis
fiscaux
cette fois ci pour deux pour de bon et
surtout sa complète
l'idée que maintenant les états cesse de
se faire concurrence mais coopère pour
la perception de l'impôt donc le là
c'est vraiment un changement ce qu'on
pourra dire c'est un vrai changement de
paradigme alors maintenant contrairement
à ce que dit wie die et que c'est un
changement historique
oui oui oui ça je le crois alors
simplement
contrairement à ce que dit bruno le
maire évidemment en fait là c'est vrai
que la france défend dé ça mais elle est
pas pour grand chose dans ce résultat le
le déclencheur c'est évidemment le
changement aux états unis mais derrière
le changement aux états unis c'est aussi
évidemment l'épidémie de kobe d'
parce que si vous voulez le le cycle de
politique économique c'est complètement
renversées donc à partir de 1979
jusqu'au krach mais ça c'était encore on
a eu ce grand cycle de désinflation de
baisse des taux d'intérêt baisse des
interventions de l'état baisse des
dépenses publiques baisse des impôts et
ça aujourd'hui ça a été d'abord fracassé
par le krach de 2008
aujourd'hui on a complètement changé
donc il ya une nouvelle donne avec
reconfigurer ration de la mondialisation
blocs régionaux avec ray intervention
des états avec montée des dépenses
publiques et quand il a monté des
dépenses publiques il ya montée des
impôts donc ça c'est vrai que c'est ça
la vraie explication
un dernier mot sur la france c'est que
donc à court terme ça va nous permettre
de récupérer sans doute 4 à 5 milliards
d'impôts en plus donc c'est une bonne
chose c'est aussi une bonne chose parce
que ça va réintégrer dans l'état de
droit et dans la fiscalité le secteur
numérique
en revanche la france elle va être en
porte-à-faux complet avec cette nouvelle
donne parce que la france elle n'a
jamais baissé ni ses dépenses publiques
ni ses impôts donc le et que la france
est complètement à contre-courant et
donc le problème française c'est qu'il
faut en france c'est vital de baisser
néanmoins les dépenses publiques et on
peut pas monter les impôts on vous a
préparé les chiffres là le taux maximum
le taux maximal de l'impôt sur les robes
de l'impôt sur les sociétés aux états
unis on est à 21% en france on est à 31%
alors emmanuel macron a promis que ça
allait baisser mais c'est encore très
élevés alors que des pays comme
l'irlande par exemple sont à 12 et demi
pourcent d'ailleurs l'actrice cros qui
le dit je n'y crois pas l'irlande ou le
luxembourg ne sont rien sans un impôt
sur les sociétés très bas donc il doute
que ces pays se laissent convaincre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez avec ce
qu'on a vécu est ce que c'est un
véritable changement de paradigme où est
ce que c'est un effet de communication
il est trop tôt pour le d'odiah je crois
que les dirigeants de la planète pour la
plupart en tout cas rêve depuis
longtemps d'une forme de gouvernement
mondial
donc je doute pas qu'il soit sincère
simplement philosophiquement je suis pas
persuadé que ce soit la meilleure
approche pour régler nos problèmes sans
doute l'aller les intentions sont bonnes
est ce que la méthode
de l'impôt mondiale et la bonne je ne
suis pas sûr parce que je crois que le
gouvernement
mondial à deux désavantages et il
condamne bien souvent les gouvernements
nationaux à l'impuissance puisque quand
il faut se mettre d'accord à 7 à 27 c
souvent bien compliqué et ça aboutit
généralement finalement à l'impuissance
et au manque d'action et ensuite c'est
un désavantage c'est que sa coupe un peu
plus et on est aussi on est dans une
crise économique une crise sociale on
sort d'une crise sanitaire mais on est
aussi dans une crise démocratique et ça
contribue finalement à éloigner les
peuples du pouvoir de décision donc
cette volonté d'aller toujours plus loin
vers des décisions qui sont prises à
plusieurs dans des mollahs de manière
opaque ne paraît pas être le moyen ni
d'être efficace politiquement ni d'être
compris démocratiquement
je reviens à l'interpellation de notre
internaute criss cross puis à chardons
bleus qui nous dit il y aura toujours
des possibilités pour ceux qui veut pour
ceux qui le souhaitent de s'affranchir
de cet impôt et puis gisèle aussi du
neuf et jouissant pas trop vite cet
impôt minimum de 15% ne pourra se mettre
en place car la condition que les
paradis fiscaux donnent leur aval moi je
serai le mot ministre de l'irlande
je dirais mais moi je suis pas d'accord
je garde mon système à moi parce que oui
mais cette et pays qui attire les grands
engagements et c'est là où système est
intelligent et où nous internautes se
trompe c'est que l'irlande peut
parfaitement gardé 6 12 5%
sauf que ça permet à la france de taxer
2 5% le dire à la zone vous vendait en
france donc exactement est en réalité
vous faites remonter vos profits en
irlande et donc moi je récupère la
différence entre les 15% lé 12 5%
et contrairement à ce que disait
alexandre ii vecchio c'est pas du tout
un gouvernement mondial
le g7 s'est des états le g20 qui va
approuver ça c'est des états le problème
c'est qu'on avait des entreprises
mondiales
il faut voir que rien que les gaffes en
avait
accumuler une masse de 2000 milliards de
dollars de profits entre les états unis
et l'europe avec l'irlande qui n'était
accès par personne et c'est une
aberration et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on a tous les pays développés et les
dettes des pays développés ces 137 % du
pib en moyenne
c'est complètement absurde on a une
révolution numérique qui on avait mis un
système où les entreprises qui porte
cette révolution numérique était
quasiment en dehors de l'impôt donc et
évidemment c'est pas la france seule ou
l'allemagne seul qui va pouvoir mettre
en place une taxation soit donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est pas du
tout un gouvernement mondial c'est une
règle mondial a en revanche et c'est ça
l'intérêt c'est à dire que pour ces
entreprises qui évoluent partout dans le
monde
elles vont être attrapé mais elles vont
pas être rattrapé par un gouvernement
mondial
elles vont être rattrapés par les
gouvernements donc la france sera en
position de faire payer un impôt de 15 %
sur les opérations faites sur le
territoire français y compris par des
entreprises qui sont des entreprises
mondialisées
mais évidemment et c'est l'état français
qui le fera et personne d'autre donc si
la france décide de ne pas le faire
c'est son problème mais est donc vous
voyez c'est pas du tout un espèce de big
brother mondial qu'il a décidé de qui
paie l'impôt où et comment non c'est
bien les états la règle est mondiale
chaque état pourra s'en prévaloir
mais ce sont les états qui ont l'affairé
alexandre vous qui n'est pas un libéral
échevelé quand même que des
multinationales américaines de sonora
soit plus taxés çà çà çà çà vous font
rien pour ça que je dis ma clé les
intentions les intentions étaient bonnes
encore faudra voir voilà je suis
d'accord avec deco la bernoise comment
est réinvesti cet argent où elle ce qui
est vrai ce qui est est ce que
finalement il installe pas certains
états comme le nôtre dans un confort
voilà ça c'est des questions qu'il
faudra poser mais mais mais je compte
attendu un peu je cours je poste voilà
mais je pense que non non ça va
effectivement ça va effectivement dans
le bon sens je suis un peuple et je
demande à voir si ça va mal à ces six à
rentrer en application effective
et je disais juste il y à il ya une
forme de sincérité parce que je crois
que les gouvernants veulent aller aller
dans le futur vers cela
donc donc ça peut se faire mon avis
ponctuellement sur de grandes règles qui
font consensus comme celle là si c'est
un dispositif pour aller justement un
gouvernement technocratique éloigné des
peuples je suis pas sûr que ça va
fonctionner je suis pas et les traités
bon c'est bien mais mais voilà c'est il
ya ceux qui les respectent qui sont
généralement les idiots utiles et pied
il ya ceux qui ont toujours encore et
toujours le pouvoir
de les violer parce que c'est comme ça
c'est la loi du plus fort entre états
donc c'était juste pour introduire une
réflexion plus globale sur le finalement
l'hypocrisie de ccr est grand voir
règlement moi je crois quand même je
crois à la coopération entre états mais
aussi au rapport de force
ah non mais la vérité désagréable le
problème c'est pas le gouvernement
mondial mais la vraie vérité c'est que
si ça a changé c'est parce que les états
unis ont changé
oui parce que cette année c'est ça le ça
fait des années que l'europe en
particulier la france où on paie des
niveaux d'impôts totalement remis ses
lattes et essaie d'introduire un minimum
d'harmonisation et s'était bloquée et
des années que l'irlande semble aux yeux
des bras d'honneur
oui c'était bloqué par irlandais
luxembourg puisque sur les sujets
fiscaux au sein de l'union il faut
l'unanimité et donc effectivement il ya
deux états les plus de temps en temps
chypre ou malte qui pouvait aussi
rajouter une petite pincée mais les deux
c'était irlandais et luxe en bois mais
le blocage mondiale s'est elle était les
états unis et les états unis ont changé
sur deux choses d'abord sur l'impôt avec
mais aussi l'autre grand changement
c'est que il ya quand même eu un pendant
très longtemps un consensus aux états
unis compte tenu du côté stratégie que
des gars femmes pour les laisser
largement en dehors de l'état de droit
du droit de la concurrence et de la
fiscalité
et ça c'est terminé depuis 2016 les
interférences russe et ensuite les
scandales à répétition autour de
l'économie des données donc maintenant
le monde politique américain veut
réintégrer les gaffes à dans l'état de
droit dans la concurrence aidant la
fiscalité et c'est ça en fait ces salles
qui a débloqué le dossier grec sont
commencés par donald trump qui volent et
même l'année une forme de consensus qui
volent et même les démanteler
les rapports un peu con il avait une
autre position mais sur le gaz c'est
vrai que le retournement ses frais
favorable à la création d'un impôt
minimum sur les multinationales
c'est la question que nous vous posons
et vous répondez oui à 60 18 % il ya
cette réaction dominium qui va plutôt
dans le sens d'alexandre ii vecchio
personnellement cela ne me plaît pas
qu'un gouvernement mondial fixe la
manière de gérer un pays sans l'avis des
citoyens
c'est vrai qu objectivement les
irlandais ils doivent pas être abusé de
deux ce qui va se passer ça c'est ça
s'est mis en place contre le contre leur
avis donc les pays qui sont peut-être un
peu plus vertueux et qui ont des impôts
plus faibles ben voilà et peut-être
qu'ils se disent c'est un peu une prime
à la halle à ceux qui sont le plus
j'appelle rizzuto mondiale sur le fait
de l'irlande
d'abord entre 12,5 et 15 % l'écart est
pas très grand et que même si l'irlande
passe à 15% comme vous l'avez rappelé
par rapport à la france qui est à 31
et si dieu le veut qui passera à 25
il y aura quand même un écart de 10 %
donc en réalité l'irlande le l'irlande
ne va pas mourir de cette nouvelle norme
internationale
est ce que l'on est en train de tourner
peut-être pour les gars femmes
alexandre ii vecchio on y avait hier il
y avait la semaine dernière par don pour
le big bang du figaro une interview de
la commissaire européenne à la
concurrence par quatre gestes et guerre
qui disait maintenant c'est fini on
n'accepte plus de se faire dicter notre
loi par par les gars femmes le vent
tourne
c'est beaucoup pour tout vous dire
effectivement l'inflexion est pas
totalement nouvelle elle a commencé à
donner avec donald trump mais aussi avec
la montée de des révoltes électorale
populiste en occident depuis depuis une
dizaine d'années donc on peut penser
qu'on est dans la fin finalement de ce
qu'on appelait la mondialisation
heureuse et que même les gouvernements
plus orthodoxes finalement s'aligne sur
le diagnostic de ce qu'ils combattaient
il ya peu dans ce cas là je suis plutôt
pour m'en réjouir
il mais je ne suis pas entièrement
certains comme les i married d'être
pessimisme qu'on sort quand même d'une
crise de la pandémie qui a
considérablement renforcé encore sega
femme qui a accéléré finalement là la
numérisation du monde
je me dis que c'est aussi dans leur
intérêt peut-être de payer plus d'impôts
surtout qu'il va y avoir des dégâts
terribles en termes de chômage et s'il
va falloir financer nos chômeurs ne
serait-ce pour qu'ils consomment
dugas femme si j'ose dire
donc est ce que c'est vrai mais
véritablement un retour en force du
politique ou est ce que c'est un
compromis qui va permettre d'aller vers
une sorte de de revenu universel et où
les politiques finalement seront
peut-être encore plus soumis qu'avant
aux gars femmes
je n'en sais rien l'avenir le dira mais
la colle à la question est ouverte et
passionnante à l'avenir tranchera c'est
une excellente conclusion d'une
télévision merci à tous les deux merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis et à demain
pour un nouveau rendez vous avec point
de vue